commentaire me l'émission avec les dix
questions
je vous ai soumise comme atout mais
inviter votre nos préférés qui bedos
amour le mot que vous détestez mort
votre drogue favorite après ce le son le
bruit que leurs doses dès le son le
bruit que vous aimez le rire d'un enfant
et le son le bruit que vous détestez les
pleurs d'un enfant je peux c'est bien
votre juron gros mot blasphème favori
[ __ ] de dieu
homme ou femme pour illustrer un nouveau
billet de banque
paul loup sulitzer l'a mérité je le
mettais que vous n'auriez pas aimé faire
un flic la plante l'arbre où l'animal
dans lequel vous aimeriez être réincarné
je ne détesterais pas être un loup parce
que je pense à la fable de la fontaine
au loup et le chien aime il ya le loup
et l'agneau
oui mais tant pis pour les agneaux alors
si dieu existe qu aimeriez vous après
votre mort l'entendre vous dire
réveille toi c'était pour rire
[Musique]